hey Youtubers, it's Charlie grab your eggos
season 2 stranger things let's break it down
H.P. Lovecraft eat your heart out the great God
Cthulhu tentacles coming from the sky I totally
love this.
So this is just the beginning they'll be a
lot more season 2 stranger things happening,
so be sure to subscribe to get everything
and if you think of anything that you really
want me to do a bonus video on wall were talking
about this trailer just let me know in the
comments below, so a lot of you probably saw
the teaser picture of the Ghostbusters this
is in 1984.
That's the year.
The Ghostbusters came out.
So this is a year after season 1 of the dimensional
portal is still open will came back coughing
up those slugs from the upside down world
in the teaser language that Netflix has been
using is that the world is upside down the
entire world the big monster the end with
the red clouds looks very war of the world.
So it's almost like our world is now becoming
or being taken over by the upside down world.
So there's the will thing to like is the things
that he's drawing turning to actual thing,
so he draws the picture of the demagorgon
demagorgon manifests does that mean that he's
also creating all these problems to because
there's a drawing of that big giant monster
that we see the end of the trailer, so a lot
of people felt like the fact that will didn't
come forward and asked for help when he came
back when he was coughing slugs up is because
it happened in the past and he didn't want
to be taken away and Eleven is back they left
the goes at the end so that kind of told you
that she was coming back.
I don't think that anybody actually thought
that she was dead, but they open this with
the funny Eggo trailer preceding her.
So just meant to remind you that this takes
place during the 80s get you in the mind of
that time.
The other big theory about all this craziness,
the upside down world the demagorgon was did
Eleven have some responsibility in creating
it because it always seem to stay in proximity
to her whenever she showed up.
It seemed to show up she made advantage by
taking it back to the upside down world herself
will so she's connected to the upside down
world the same way that will as they just
haven't explained that yet it's 1 of those
things they have to pay off in season 2 this
alternate dimension because actually do think
that it is a real place that fundamentally
changes the people that spend time there for
any extended.
So with the dimensional portal open.
A lot of those things will be running loose
on earth there.
You get your Ghostbusters but also people
will be changing themselves.
So the whole season is supposed to address
the consequences of will spending that week,
in the upside down world all this crazy stuff
at the Department of Energy they added a couple
big cast members to their big callbacks to
80s flakes like this there's Paul Reiser from
aliens you think about the demagorgon like
wondering how much Ridley Scott craziness
is going to be happening in Sean Aston from
goonies so course is going to be awesome.
They released this viral teaser that tells
you a storm is coming.
A lot of people decoded it and thought that
it meant that the season was going to be dropping
September 8, 2017, but actually revealed that
your Ghostbusters cosplay hollowing costumes
are really more of a hat tip to the release
date.
So is actually coming on October 31 Halloween
this year.
So that's what all the episodes will drop
the really blending the idea of what is real
what is fiction what is the game.
So the fun Easter egg really from that first
episode.
If you go back and rewatch the series is that
the game they play the Dungeons & Dragons
almost tells the exact story of what happens
during the entire series Shallcross the wall
swallowing darkness will demagorgon and the
special stress is endemic was in the morning
Army Sgt. his shoulder that told you to Pull
Loan Think of the Truck Likes to Keep Something
Else to The Protection so Cast Protection
Some Sort, so They Might Lay Easter Eggs in
the First Episode of Season 2 That Way They
Have Some Sort of Moment or a Game or Conversation
It Foreshadows Everything That's Going to
Be Happening.
Netflix Isn't Holding Back Anything, They
Have These Teasers Where They Say Monsters
Are Coming There Dressed As Ghostbusters.
So They're Going to Be Lots of Demo Gourds
Running around People Turning into Monsters
Things Going Crazy Is Going to Be Awesome
and Get a Load of the Episode Titles.
They Board He Released Them All.
There's Nine Episodes Instead of Eight like
Season 1.
So Episode 1 to Episode Nine Here We Go Mad
Max the Boy Who Came Back to Life Talking
about Will the Pumpkin Patch the Palace the
Storm Talking about These Red Storm Clouds
the Pollywog the Secret Cabin the Brain and
the Lost Brother.
So We Can Talk about What Those Episode Titles
Might Need in Future Bonus Videos, but I Will
Be Doing a Couple Season 2 Videos As Many
As Possible, It's a Little Harder to Do Videos
for Every Single Episode for Something That
Drops All the Same Time, so Usually like with
the Marvel Netflix Stuff at the Change the
Way I Do the Videos Just a Little Bit, but
It's a Long Ways off Are Going to Beginning
about This All Year.
It's Gonna Be Great.
Let Me Know like What Are All You Guys Questions
in the Comments below, It's 1 of Those Series
That's Very Ambiguous about Things.
So Just Lends Itself to A Lot Of Theory Crafting
There Couple New or Younger Characters, the
Title of the Lost Brother It Might Be 1 of
Those New Younger Characters, but They'll
Probably Reveal Whole Bunch More Information
through the Rest of the Year.
So I'll Do Videos As They Reveal Stuff Let
Me Know What You Guys Think about This and
Everybody Was Freaking out about It Just Because
It Seems so Crazy by the End.
Just Remember in a David Kr1nberg Anything
from the 80s Is Fair Game in Terms of Genre
and Other Related Netflix News Iron Fist Is
Going to Be Dropping March 17.
Of Course I'm in Be Doing a Bunch of Videos
for They'll Probably Be a New Trailer Very
Soon in the Next Week or so so.
Just Look out for That.
And If There Are Any Iron Fist or Marvel Netflix
Bonus Videos You Guys Want Me to Do.
Also Let Me Know in the Comments There's A
Lot Of Netflix Stuff Coming, in Addition to
All the Regular TV and Movie Stuff.
It's Gonna Be Great While You Wait for That
You Can Click Here to Rewatch the Guardians
to Trailer and You Can Click Here to Rewatch
the Iron Fist Trailer Thank You so Much Watching
Everybody Let's High Five I'll See You in
the Next Video!